Bienvenidos a esta presentación en donde
vamos a ver el nivel 4 de ecuaciones lineales,
ya por fin llegamos al nivel 4.
Y en esta ocasión quiero ver la siguiente ecuación,
3 sobre "x" esto quiero que sea igual a 5 y
lo primero que quiero que te des cuenta,
es que en esta ecuación tenemos un gran problema, tenemos a la "x" en el denominador,
en todas las ecuaciones pasadas habíamos
tenido a "x" en el numerador,
sin embargo en esta ocasión tenemos a
"x" en el denominador,
¿cómo podemos resolver esta ecuación?
Y bueno, lo primero que hay que hacer es quitar
lo más rápido que se pueda a la "x" del
denominador y para quitar a la "x" del denominador
lo que hay que hacer es multiplicar esta ecuación
de ambos lados por "x", es decir,
"x" que multiplica a 3 sobre "x" es igual a
5 que multiplica a "x",
¿por qué?
porque si yo tengo "x" entre "x",
pues "x" entre "x" se van, es 1.
Entonces simple y sencillamente del lado izquierdo
me quedaría un 3, estos dos se van y me queda
del lado izquierdo 3, mientras que del lado
derecho me queda "5x" y ¡wow! date cuenta
que la "x" ya no está en el denominador.
Y tenemos una ecuación del nivel 1,
es decir "5x" igual a 3.
Y por lo tanto, ahora ya podemos resolver
esta ecuación.
¿Qué pasa si yo multiplico ambos lados por 1/5?
Entonces me queda, 1/5 por 5 se va, solamente me queda "x", mientras que del otro lado me queda 3/5
y date cuenta que ya hemos resuelto este problema, cuando "x" vale 3/5 se cumple
esta ecuación con la que empezamos, la cual
tenía el grave problema de tener a la "x"
como denominador, pero ahora vamos a ver qué
pasa si lo complicamos un poco más.
Déjame borrar la pantalla y vamos a ver un ejemplo un poco más complicado en donde tengamos
a la "x", es decir, a nuestra incógnita como
denominador.
Tengo "x" más 2 entre "x" más 1, esto quiero
que sea igual a 7...
esto quiero que sea igual a 7...
y aquí tenemos un gran problema,
tenemos a la "x" tanto en el numerador
como en el denominador,
¿qué vamos a hacer? Y bueno, la respuesta es vamos a hacer lo mismo que hicimos en el ejercicio pasado.
Lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar esta ecuación de ambos lados de la ecuación por "x" más 1,
es decir, "x" más 1 entre 1, es lo mismo que "x" más 1,
por esto que está aquí y del otro lado también,
7 entre 1 por "x" más 1 entre 1.
Lo estoy poniendo entre 1 para que nos quede una multiplicación de quebrados
y veas que éste con éste se van, "x" más 1 y "x" más 1 se van, porque uno multiplica y el otro divide.
Entonces del lado izquierdo simple y sencillamente
me queda "x" más 2, mientras que del lado
derecho me queda 7 que multiplica a su vez a "x" más 1.
Y aquí tengo, "x" más 2 es igual...
y este 7 lo voy a distribuir por todo lo que
está adentro de los paréntesis, este 7 multiplica
todo lo que está adentro de los paréntesis,
por lo tanto, utilizando la propiedad distributiva
me va a quedar "7x" más 7 y a continuación,
si yo lo que quiero es despejar a "x", voy
a restar "7x" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
estas son las ecuaciones que veíamos en el
video pasado, son las ecuaciones del nivel 3.
Y por lo tanto recuerda que lo que hay que hacer es pasar todo lo que tenga que ver con la variable "x"
de un lado de la ecuación, en esta ocasión
voy a decidir en lado izquierdo
y por lo tanto, lo que voy a hacer es restar "7x" de ambos lados de la ecuación,  de tal manera que este "7x"
y este "-7x" se vayan, se cancelen y por otro lado me queda "-7x" más "x", lo cual es -6 veces "x",
"-6x" más 2, esto es igual a... estos dos se fueron y solamente me queda del lado derecho el 7.
Y bueno, ahora tengo este 2 que me estorba,
recuerda que lo que hay que hacer es restar
2 de ambos lados de la ecuación, para que
queden todos los números de un lado de la
ecuación y todo lo que tenga que ver con
la incógnita del otro lado de la ecuación y entonces obtengo, "-6x" es igual a 7 menos 2, lo cual es 5
y si ahora multiplico por el recíproco de -6, lo cual es -1/6, ya voy a obtener el valor de "x",
es decir, estamos en las ecuaciones del nivel 1,
en las ecuaciones fáciles.
Voy a multiplicar por el recíproco de
ambos lados de la ecuación,
-1/6, -1/6 y -1/6 que multiplica a -6, estos dos se van porque esto me da 1,
entonces del lado izquierdo solamente me queda "x", mientras que del lado derecho
me queda 5 por -1/6, lo cual es -5/6,
"x" es igual a -5/6.
Y ya está, lo hemos logrado, ya tenemos el
valor de "x" que satisface esta ecuación
y de hecho sería bastante bueno que tú te
dieras a la tarea de poner este valor de "x"
aquí en la ecuación original sustituyendo nuestro valor que acabamos de encontrar para
comprobar que realmente llegamos a una igualdad.
Pero bueno, vamos a hacer otro ejercicio,
otro ejercicio que tenga que ver con esto
que estamos viendo.
3 entre "x" más 5 quiero que esto esa igual
a 8 entre "x" más 2.
Ahora sí, tengo el "x" más 5 en el denominador
de la parte izquierda de la ecuación,
mientras que tengo el "x" más 2 en el denominador
de la parte derecha de esta ecuación.
¿Cómo se resuelve esto?
Pues bueno, la idea es más o menos la misma,
lo que voy a hacer primero es quitar el "x"
más 5 del lado izquierdo de la ecuación
y para eso voy a multiplicar de ambos lados
de la ecuación por "x" más 5, por "x" más
5, por "x" más 5 para que estos dos se vayan
y me queda simple y sencillamente 3 del lado
izquierdo de la ecuación, mientras que del
lado derecho me queda 8 que multiplica a su
vez a "x" más 5, pero esto dividido entre
"x" más 2, porque aquí tenemos "x" más
2 que multiplica a 1 y por lo tanto, todavía
tenemos a la "x" en el denominador, pero bueno,
primero voy a distribuir este 8 para ver qué me queda.
3 es igual a "8x" más 40 entre "x" más 2
y bueno, sigo teniendo este "x" más 2 en
el denominador, ahora para quitarlo, lo que
voy a hacer es multiplicar otra vez esta ecuación,
pero ahora lo voy a multiplicar por "x" más
2, por "x" más 2, por "x" más 2 ó por "x"
más 2 entre 1, de tal manera que se pueda
cancelar con este "x" más 2, 3 que multiplica
a "x" más 2 voy a distribuir el 3 y me queda
"3x" más 6, recuerda que lo único que estoy
haciendo es usando la propiedad distributiva,
3 por "x" más 3 por 2 y del lado derecho,
¿qué me va a quedar?
"x" más 2 y "x" más 2, ¡vámonos!
entonces solamente me queda "8x" más 40 ó "8x" más 40 entre 1, pero pues esto
es lo mismo que "8x" más 40 y ya tengo una ecuación de las mismas que vimos en el video pasado,
voy a restar "8x" de ambos lados de la ecuación,
¿y qué me va a quedar?
Pongo "-8x" del lado izquierdo, "-8x" del
lado derecho, bueno, pues del lado derecho
"8x" menos "8x" se van y del lado izquierdo
me queda "-8x" más "3x", lo cual es "-5x",
"-5x" más 6 es igual a 40. Y bueno, ahora voy a pasar el 6 del otro lado de la ecuación
y para esto lo que voy a hacer es restar 6 de ambos lados de la ecuación,
-6 aquí, -6 acá, de tal suerte que más
6 menos 6 se van...
y ya no tengo espacio, así que déjame ponerlo
todo la continuación por acá.
Y me va a quedar -6 más 6, pues estos dos
se van y solamente del lado derecho me queda
"-5x", "-5x" porque el 6 y el -6 se cancelaron,
mientras que del lado derecho me queda 40
menos 6, lo cual es 34.
Y si ahora lo que quiero es despejar a "x"
y ya estamos en nuestras ecuaciones del nivel
1, lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar por el
recíproco de -5, que es -1/5, -1/5, -1/5,
me queda que "x" es igual a -34/5,
porque -1/5 por -5 se van y espero que no me haya equivocado, según yo va todo en orden
y ya estás preparado para resolver cualquier
ecuación de nivel 4.
Nos vemos pronto.